- I know of the fish.
I hear those are good.
(synthesized music)
- [Voiceover] Tyrkish Peber.
- Oh, oh no.
- What are these?
- Okay, is this legit, looks like a rock.
- They're advertising them as charcoal.
- One, two.
- Licorice.
- So bad, so bad, so bad!
- Ugh!
- So do Swedish people
think this is spicy?
- Now I wanna make it hot.
- Now I think if we bite
into it, it'll get spicy.
- Yeah.
- One, two, three.
- I mean, black licorice is
already the worst candy ever.
- Yeah, why would you salt it?
- Something just exploded in my mouth.
- It's not spicy, it's just awful.
- [Voiceover] Happy Chews.
That's a really cute name (laughs).
- Those look nice.
- A lot of these are resembling stones.
- These are weird candies.
- Yeah.
- Ohhhh, marshmallow.
- Okay.
- Oh, ooh!
- Is that minty?
- Sour.
- Sour?
- And sour.
- Ooh, it's sour.
- This looks like it's gonna be caramel.
- Mhmm.
- But then it's not!
- They really know how to play
this flavor roller coaster.
- Yeah, it's like fruity.
- It has a good chewiness.
- I like these.
- [Voiceover] Ahlgrens Bilar.
- Oh.
- Are these swedish fish?
- Are these marshmallows?
- They look kinda like
gum that someone chewed up
and then spit out.
- Oh, man!
Now it's like all I'm
gonna be thinking about.
- I think they're little rabbits.
- I think they're like little automobiles.
- No, they're cars.
- Traditional sedan!
- Sedan.
- 1953.
- Yeah, 1953 makes sense.
- Oh, this is horrible.
- I could package something
fragile with these.
- Mmm!
- Think it's good.
- It's different.
- It's really hard to chew.
- I would eat a whole bag
of these at the movies.
- The pink one's better.
Okay, I might spend my money on this.
- I like 'em.
- [Voiceover] Kryptoniter?
- [Voiceover] Sura & Salta.
- This looks like grandma's soap.
- What's with all the black candy?
- These are glistening,
and I don't like that.
- Yeah, I don't know
if these are sweating.
- Taste like medicine.
- This is pleasant.
It's like, vaguely strawberry.
- But it's not really like warhead level.
- Dude, there's something inside.
Oh, it's salt!
- Wooh!
- Oh God, I just got the salt.
- Where's the trash?
- I just tasted sugar and then sour.
- Mine released a puff of salt.
- I will say, though, this
lasts a really long time.
- [Voiceover] Happy Chokladkola.
- I don't know.
I'm just having a hard time trusting
the Swedish people right now.
- I'm excited for this one.
- Mh, hmm.
- Is it marshmallow?
(laughs)
- That's fun.
- I love this.
Do you love this?
- I actually do.
- This is amazing.
- Oh my God, why is this
not a girl scout cookie?
- It tastes like ice cream.
- Yeah.
- Without the coldness.
- They weren't that weird.
They were just different.
- All of these have been
constantly surprising.
None of these have been what I expect.
- I think, you know, after eating this,
I would be like, "Oh yeah,
I would visit Sweden."
- Hey, Happy Chokladkola.
- Yeah, Happy Chokladkola.
- Let's take the rest of the day off,
Happy Chokladkola everybody.
- Tyrkish Peber.
- Tyrkish, is that like
their Justin Beiber?
Have you been listening to Tyrkish Peber?
He's so good.
- Oh my God, but I hate him.
- No, I love him.
He's like, oh!